generally what Drew you to fortnite
initially because you got addicted to
the game yeah so well brand deal right
right
okay okay but we've all had brand deals
okay not every brand deal that we do
that we get we're like okay I'm probably
the worst to say this because I get
addicted to every brand deal that I get
sent so I I I get it but like what what
about the game Drew to it and kept you
playing afterwards I'm sure it wasn't
the only brand deal you got right no no
for sure yeah it was so I guess did the
brand and the video performed well right
yeah right so that's definitely gonna
fire off that uh that dopamine kick for
sure and it's like all right I want
another kick give me get let's go again
um uh yeah just
pretty much getting back in there I was
actually challenging to win as well
um like very in the early days so it was
you know actual fun experience to try
and win a game
um so like just recounting that and then
like you know you're throwing these
little challenges where it's like okay
can I use a certain color weapon and
like that spicy for a bit and you could
do kind of videos with other people in
the community
I don't really know what like just kept
me there though I I honestly it was just
fun
was it not overrated now now it wasn't
is it now is the question right like I
don't know it's kind of a bit you think
it's changed or anything well it's it's
gone through two massive stages at least
I mean
um when I played fortnite when I when I
did uh it was kind of I liked it and
then you know I didn't play it for like
a two two three months and then it it
was crushing it because all the Thanos
stuff and then I came back to play it
like a year later and everyone was
insane at building so if you don't know
fortnite has this mechanic where what
made it unique is a battle royale was
that you could build structures right
right but honestly structures you could
build vertical walls floors or ceilings
and then like ramps yeah and the whole
idea is that you should build pretty
quickly to move or make it make a cover
right and it's a cool system and it made
sense but then what ended up happening
was that people started getting insanely
good at building right yeah like and I
mean like Fast yeah it's like let's say
you found someone someone would erect
like a whole [__] structure that was
like yeah like 0.1 seconds like this guy
and then I I'd be playing against him
like this [__] sucks I'm logging off
yeah I don't want to [__] play this
is something horrible for beginners yeah
and I think that's when it started to
kind of slow down a little bit and then
they had this massive idea where they
were like fortnite is falling off let's
remove building so they just moved the
entire mechanic and they were like guys
it's good again and that was that like
whole kind of pitch trying to get people
back into it am I correct and saying
yeah no got a lot of the casuals back
yeah for sure that like reminisce on the
old times yeah definitely got a few of
them back here I think I think the way I
found out about it I just remembered
this was when they did that collab with
like Travis Scott yeah oh yeah the
Travis Scott and marshmallow concert
yeah like I think that's how I found out
about it because I was like you didn't
find out about fortnite until then I had
known about it but I remember I remember
when the Travis Scott console was
happening that was like all over the
Internet because it's like fortnite this
[__] game somehow Hal got like a
serious like mainstream artist to do
like a virtual concert in their game and
I'm like what yeah how did that happen
and then he did the [__] McDonald's
thing and I'm like okay this guy will
shop for a check anyway
always comes back to McDonald's
yeah I think for me like I always knew
about fortnite but I I think the moment
I realized how big it was was I guess
one ninja who was just overnight it felt
like overnight just became like the
biggest streamer and like the face of
like twitch and gaming for like a while
yeah uh and just like the the first like
Esports event that they did as well
where they had like the [__]
ridiculous prize pool yeah 100 yeah I
think it was 30 mil there's 100 Mil
throughout the year they spent on
competitive yeah yeah World Cup went
crazy yeah I I played in the um not the
solos and the Duos where like all the
prize was I was in like the creative one
okay so like as a team captain became
dead last okay
how much I go for dead loss 20 bucks no
this is fortnite here
300K I'm pissed about it to be honest
yeah there's literally like a clip of me
in the last game because it was like it
was like a they're like parkour you guys
like parkour games they run around don't
fall off yeah essentially like yeah
actually have to like not fall in the
lava literally that right okay so it was
a lot of like that different type of
competitive aspect and so they're all
these like professional parkour Runners
that we build as a team professional
yeah they bagged out 300K so
um but I remember those like on the last
game like my team had died
and I was sitting out I just literally
sat there emote crying knowing I can't
[__] win like did you did you go to a
physical location finally this was at
the World Cup it was the day before in
New York what was the uh all the way out
to New York from Australia yeah I was in
Toronto at the time so it was an easy
flight all right okay okay how did he
qualify for that uh well that one I was
a captain so like I was like you chose
the team I chose the team yeah yeah so
it was like kind of I made a map and
people qualified by like running my map
really fast okay well we took him over
and got dead last was it was this
because you were already like
pre-established so yeah like okay we
want you to be a team captain or did was
there like an actual like qualification
process no it was it was very much that
yeah okay it was like me ninja uh
scissors uh and a bunch of other
International creators so you had to
just be a captain of four random people
you'd never met before yeah how was that
yeah you met them in person I sure yeah
yeah you must be so bizarre yeah it's
like oh while you guys a goats you ran
my map really quick like let's try and
bag out now let's do
[__] me
yeah between five no like 200k 50k I
think 58 each yeah
USD by the way
okay fortnite was handing out these bags
that they never handed out anymore
like yo that's why it's overrated yeah
they don't have the bag
no I mean they are handing out like uh
like I don't know if you guys saw like
the the Unreal Engine fortnite
announcement like it took over Twitter
for a couple days and was like whoa this
is fortnite now and it's like
essentially you can like water for this
yep yeah you would you would have seen
all the timeline
um so that's like a big thing where like
now 40 of the revenue that comes out of
the item shop gets split between Play
Time on Battle Royale and creative maps
that are made right so like they had nap
bags there that's that's a definitely a
good place so you can literally become
like I guess making it your job yeah in
like uh
that's like the the roadblocks yeah it
is literally the Roblox five Roblox does
so well they give people who make the
most popular Maps a lot of money well
they don't even give them the money they
actually give them tokens right well so
they don't have this in fortnite but
Roblox
you can sell things in the game for
Robux you can get like a gun in the game
yeah and it's very like kind of pay to
win kind of yeah
but roblox's system is very very
questionable yeah it is a lot of like
very [__] they have a whole Stock
Exchange which they shouldn't have well
in game yeah like a legit like
functioning oh yeah I know for the items
yeah yeah something worth like hundreds
of thousands yeah and it's like yeah and
bear in mind this is for kids youngest
demographic in gaming probably they
should not I I just I just got hit
um I'm I'm becoming my dad now no I was
just about to say I'm like this is what
this is this is what my dad must feel
like when I hear about like
[__] I [__] get it like you might
okay imagine your kid comes along it's
like Mom Dad I'm gonna become a
professional fortnite map Builder and
you're just like I get it now because
I'm like this is how my dad must have
felt when I said I wanted to be a
YouTuber why are you sad son box went
down two points yesterday
you know I just sold and there's
um there's been like a lot of stories in
Roblox about dudes like basically just
getting like kids to make maps for them
yeah yeah
like get a bunch of kids and they'll
make them make stuff for them and then
they'll just take all the money yeah
dude who like yeah it's really [__]
[__] yeah it's it's it's such a weird
it's about not trying to compare four
attacks actually sounds like it has a
pretty good system yeah Traders but like
Roblox has gone down the other route
where it's like we will literally give
anyone money as long as you make stuff
wait did you do any like Roblox content
at all no I actually oh I did like I
dabbled a little bit but like I didn't
get into it at all right
um but yeah I I used to run like
Minecraft servers yeah um yeah that was
my first kind of experience like running
a business I guess
um because those would run away where
it's like come on and you pay for a rank
and then it's like you know building
content and then filming a series to
help promote the server that was like
really fun for me back in the day yeah I
saw uh I saw I was looking through your
channel this morning and I was like oh I
see you're one of the Minecraft
youtubers who were doing parody songs
yeah
I didn't sing them though I just like
produced them right yeah that was fun
yeah there was some I think that's
actually my most viewed video yeah
yeah dude I remember because like back
in the day man like when when Minecraft
was that it's like first first Peak
there was like all the big Minecraft
creators were doing these parody songs
they were getting stupid views yep
I'd ever really make money because they
get claimed I think that one's claimed
oh really yeah it was like a parody of a
propolis yeah yeah Captain Sparkles did
a bunch of well his one of them he had
to change the song completely oh my um
one of his OG ones but like I think the
big ones are like still good it depends
like your relationship with diamond
swords from Tobuscus yeah
some OG internet like gold there in that
era